inciso b para qué intervalo contenido en
menos 3 menor que x menor que 4 la
gráfica de f es cóncava hacia abajo y
además está decreciendo justifica tu
respuesta bueno pues esta vez queremos
que la función
efe se apuntaba hacia abajo y además
este decreciente ok entonces qué te
parece si primero recordamos que
significa tener una función cóncava
hacia abajo entonces lo voy a notar con
este color
efe es cóncava hacia abajo
hacia abajo
si pasa que bueno nosotros sabemos que f
es con capacidad bajo si y sólo si qué
pasa con su segunda derivada
bueno pues su segunda derivada ésta
tiene que ser menor que cero estás de
acuerdo y bueno
la segunda derivada es menor que cero sí
sólos y qué pasa con la primera derivada
bueno la segunda derivada es menor que
cero si la primera derivada está
decreciendo si f prima de x decrece muy
bien esto es lo que sabemos para una
función que es cóncava hacia abajo ahora
qué pasa si una función decrece
qué pasa si f decrece bueno si una
función decrecer que es lo segundo que
nos piden entonces qué pasa con la
primera derivada bueno pues la pendiente
de la recta tangente de una función que
decrecen debe de ser negativa estás de
acuerdo o dicho de otra manera la tasa
de cambio de una función que decrece es
negativa eso quiere decir que su primera
derivada debe de ser menor que cero
entonces como nos dan la gráfica de este
prima de x vamos a aplicarnos en la
primera derivada y queremos que ambas
restricciones se cumplan
entonces se cumplen ambas
ambas cuando pasa que bueno cuando un f
prima de x por la primera condición que
tengo aquí decrece
y además voy a buscar que esta misma f
prima
que le pase bueno que sea menor que cero
para que así se cumpla la segunda
condición entonces voy a buscar en esta
gráfica un intervalo en donde f prima de
crezca y además f prima sea menor que
cero
bueno pues primero nos vamos a fijar en
todos los intervalos en donde f prima
sea negativa y se observa es todo esto
de aquí por aquí tenemos una función
negativa por aquí también por aquí
también es negativa por aquí se mantiene
también y bueno por aquí también todos
estos son los puntos en donde f prima de
x es menor que cero todos estos y bueno
de todos estos vamos a buscar en cuáles
se cumple que f prima de crezca y si
observas aquí justo aquí la función está
decreciendo decreciendo decreciendo
hasta llegar a este punto si observas
estamos en el intervalo
2 menor que x menor que menos 1 muy bien
aquí en este intervalo la función es
negativa y además de crecer y solamente
aquí no también aquí
si observas en este intervalo también
tenemos una función que decrece una
función que decrece de aquí aquí es
decir en el intervalo 1 menor que x
menor que 3
también estamos decreciendo justo aquí
se observa en esta parte estamos
decreciendo pero justo aquí la función
es positiva efe prima de x es positiva
así que no vamos a incluir ese intervalo
entonces ya está tenemos nuestra
solución nuestra solución son los
intervalos abiertos menos 2 menor que x
menor que menos 1 y el intervalo 1 menor
que x menor que 3 en estos dos
intervalos se cumplen ambas condiciones
y bueno observa que estos dos son
intervalos abiertos